ich denke jeder von euch hat diesen Zug
schon mal irgendwo gesehen die Rede ist
vom japanischen schinkans ich bin für
einige Zeit in Japan und habe den Zug
für einen Tag in der ersten Klasse
getestet das war ganz schön teuer aber
fangen wir von vorne an meine Reise
startet an der main station von Tokyo
von hier aus geht es knapp 500 km in die
alte Kaiserstadt Kyoto der schinkansen
packt das in gut zwei Stunden alles geht
unfassbar geordnet zu egal wo man ist
man stellt sich brav in eine Schlange
fährt der Zug ein so gehen irgendwann
die Schranken auf und man darf
einsteigen Platz gibt es mehr als genug
die meisten Züge haben allerdings kein
Bordbistro oder Service es ist nicht nur
die Geschwindigkeit die beeindruckt
schaut euch dieses aerodynamische Design
an die meisten schinkansenzüge sind weiß
so auch unser und schaffen 300 km/h in
den Norden des Landes fahren aber eher
die grünen oder roten schinkansen die
sind sogar noch mal 20 km/h schneller
von außen wirken die schinkansenzüge
super futuristisch es sieht aus als
gleiten sie durch das Land im Inneren
ist das Fahrgefühl aber eher so wie bei
uns im ICE nur man ist halt so 100%
pünktlich am Ziel bezahlt habe ich für
zwei Personen hin und zurück 410 €. für
weitere Reisevideos